first regarding the situation with the
novel coronavirus we know many of you
here in the room we are at the UN
building in Geneva I wish to welcome
everyone who is watching us alive on WH
our Twitter account and would like to
say to journalists who are watching us
that they can ask their questions using
the hashtag ask WH show we will also
have a audio file from this press
briefing later in the day and transcript
as well you have all received the media
advisory that we that we sent 20 minutes
ago the WTO director-general has decided
to reconvene emergency committee
tomorrow we will have a virtual press
conference aiming for 7:30 Geneva time
but you will bear with us if we a little
bit late so we will we will be again
with you tomorrow evening after the
meeting of the Emergency Committee but
today we are here with dr. Mike Ryan wh
the executive director for health
emergencies and dr. Maria van karakov
who you already met on couple of
occasions who is the head for interim of
emerging diseases and zone osis dr. Ryan
has just came back from his visit to
China where he accompanied dr. Tetris
and other WTO officials where they met
with health authorities and national
authorities in China you have received
the press release on that last evening
so I'll give the floor to dr. Ryan to
tell us more about this visit
a good afternoon everyone Thank You
Terry yes we dr. Ted Wes and myself
under chef the cabin a returned to
Geneva today after 1:30 p.m. so this is
our first opportunity to to brief you on
this as you will have seen the
director-general dr. Ted Russ has just
announced that he will reconvene the
International Health Regulations
Emergency Committee on the new novel
coronavirus
2019 in kobe tomorrow to advise them on
whether the current outbreak constitutes
a public health emergency of
international concern his decision to
reconvene the committee is is based
mainly on the the evidence of increasing
and numbers of cases on evidence for
human to human transmission that has
occurred outside of of China and these
developments in terms of the evolution
of the outbreak and the further
development of transmission is of great
concern and has spurred countries into
action and we're very grateful for that
action especially in China what we know
at this stage this this is still a very
obviously a very act of outbreak and
information is being updated and
changing by the hour it is clearly still
centered in China with the overwhelming
majority of cases still being reported
from China however there are 71 cases
reported in 15 other countries of no but
in those cases is the majority of those
cases apart for six hour associated with
travel to China and of those the vast
majority of those cases our associate
still would travel to Wuhan we're
continuing to learn more about the virus
but in doing that learning as I said we
know that the intense epidemic is
centered at MU Han and Hebei we know
that many people are experienced a minor
form of illness but still 20 percent of
reported cases are reported as severe
and
percent of confirmed cases are reported
to have died the disease is obviously
mainly respiratory disease passing via
droplets from one person to the other
I'm mostly still through close contact
the source as we've said before is still
unclear and investigations continue in
that regard
prevention of this disease is based very
much on what we recommend for
respiratory illnesses in general in
terms of keeping distance from people
who are sick and the use of respiratory
and hand hygiene and much information is
available on that on our website and has
been disseminated to member states and
the public and Maria man Kharkov who's
with me here can can give more detail on
that clearly we want people who are sick
- especially those with with coughs and
difficulty breathing to seek health care
as as soon as possible during our trip
to China we were very impressed with the
level of engagement of the Chinese
government at all levels personally I
think myself and the Director General
have never seen the scale commitment of
an epidemic response at this level in
terms of all of government involvement
across all of the different arms of
government with a tremendous support
being poured into Wuhan and who Bay from
the central government with a highly
organized emergency management structure
the challenge is great that the response
has been massive and the Chinese
government deserves huge credit for that
response and for the transparency in
which they have dealt with this a case
in point in terms of one of the the
clusters of infection that we're
currently working with Germany to
investigate it was the lab in China who
contacted Germany to tell them that they
had a return case it was positive so
China is not only helping to manage the
cases in its own country but it is
actively reaching out on an individual
basis not only to whu-oh but other
partners in the world to help them
respond in a more effective way as I
said they are take
extraordinary measures in the face of
what is an extraordinary challenge they
have in addition have agreed to a
mission of international experts to work
to go to China and work with Chinese
experts to better understand disease
transmission to better understand
clinical severity but I might add the
Chinese experts are involved in almost I
think all of our expert networks and on
a daily basis dialing into calls of the
clinical laboratory and other aspects of
this so Chinese expertise and scientific
knowledge and understanding of this
disease is contributing to the overall
global expertise but we're very grateful
that China will invite a team to help
work with them side by side to learn
more about this disease and learn more
about how China is taking action on our
side we have brought together some of
the best minds in the world scientists
clinicians disease trackers modelers
logistician supply chain experts and
many others from the public and the
private sector around the world to
examine what we know the questions we
need to answer and who is placed best
placed to deliver on those answers and
those responses hmm as I said these
networks of experts include experts from
China working directly on the response
and that frontline experience
understanding what a frontline clinician
in in Wuhan is seeing today is
influencing the way in which we can
manage potential coronavirus cases
tomorrow elsewhere we're helping other
countries to activate their preparedness
plans we clearly have force four levels
in this response we have the an intense
response going on in Mohan and Hebei
Province we have responses going on in
other provinces in China where
transmission is less intense the numbers
are less but nonetheless a major
response is under way to track cases
contacts and try to interrupt chains of
transmission we have the 15 countries
who have imported cases they have to
stop transmission some of them are doing
that extremely well all of them are
actually taking good action but some
need some help and assistance with lab
and another expertise and we're doing
that from WH Oh
but the whole world needs to be on alert
now the whole world needs to take action
and be ready for for any cases that come
either from the original epicenter or
from from other epicenters that that
become established we're sharing
information guidelines and tools in real
time on our website and through our
partner networks on how to manage the
disease how to manage community
investigations how to manage
transmission studies how to manage
clinical trials and are very grateful
for our partners who work with us on the
research and development blueprints for
our partners who work on from the global
outbreak alert and response network from
the emergency medical teams Network and
many other networks around the world who
are supporting us in this we're also
working to ensure the countries know
what supplies to get what supplies to
use through a disease commodity package
which details two countries the right
supplies in the right quantities for
certain levels of of cases that they
might expect
so those countries who have imported
cases are clearly at full alert those
countries who have not important cases
will obviously need to look at their
readiness and preparedness for some
countries this is a very straightforward
task for other countries who have
fragile and potentially vulnerable who
already have weaknesses in their public
health system this is a challenge so
whu-oh is working with those countries
to ensure that they have the basic
capacity to do Diagnostics case
detection isolation quarantine and
follow-up I believe that the world is
pulling together to respond to this
outbreak we are at an important juncture
in this event we as whu-oh believe that
this these chains of transmissions can
still be interrupted this this disease
is still spreading from person to person
through personal contact between
individuals and
through proper management of hygiene
proper management of case identification
isolation and social distancing like in
previous outbreaks of coronavirus we may
be able to working with the government
in China and other governments stuff
those transmission chains we must make
that we must be commit to doing that
together and I believe the Emergency
Committee tomorrow will consider the
merits of declaring a global public
health emergency and the merits of any
temporary contemporary recommendations
that could be made so there are all
Member States behave and act in a
coordinated and measured fashion in
response to this evolving event thank
you thank you very much Ryan so we will
start with questions we will take few
questions from the room and then we will
also take few questions from journalists
who are watching us on our Twitter
account
let me start let me start here and
please introduce yourself yes okay as
wh0 is going to send a group of
international experts to China so could
you tell us who they are and what are
the major tasks they're going to perform
in China and secondly yesterday whao
said is going to set up a novel
coronavirus data sharing platform can
you elaborate more on the what kind of
data sharing platform is going to
establish thank you okay I'll pass
debris on the data sharing platform
there is much data that we need member
states to share with us and we would
like to have that data in the most
organized and standardized format that
we can soil
I'll ask Maria to speak to that with
regards to the expert team that will go
that team is still being pulled together
but let me stress China is doing the
right things and China is responding in
a massive way this team
is in that sense if you would imagine
this team is not going to help China or
assist China it's to work in
collaboration with Chinese experts to
come to a better common understanding of
these issues and ensure that the lessons
being learned the science that's been
applied and the evidence that's being
gathered is shared with the world so I
think it's very important to understand
this mission as not an initiation of a
response the response is fully underway
in China this team is to go and learn
lessons to observe and to work with
Chinese experts to learn as much as we
can about this disease in order that
other countries may benefit from that
thank you so we mentioned yesterday in
our sitrep that we will be launching
this global novel coronavirus clinical
characterization case reporting form and
this is our attempt to work with
countries that are treating patients to
have a standardized way to collect
information about the clinical
presentation the signs and symptoms that
they may have laboratory testing and how
these patients are cared for it's very
important that we collect this in a
standardized way so that we can better
characterize what infection looks like
what disease looks like by being
infected with this virus and just in
addition we've asked all Member States
who import cases to share with us on a
daily basis standardized data format for
cases for contacts both aggregates and
disaggregated data which will allow us
to build a comprehensive global database
and track the spread and the evolution
of this epidemic so we are asking our
Member States not only to collect data
for the wrong purposes but to share that
surveillance data with us so we can
build a proper global picture of the
epidemic thank you Jeremie Dan Brisse
from Bloomberg hi Jeremy Knost from the
French public way quick questions
did you learn anything major from your
trip in China second question would be
about the sharing of the genetic
sequence of the virus Australia
announced that it shared today the
entire virus in contrary with what
China did was only the genetic sequence
I'd like to know the difference there
and if it's something major - and the
last question will be something more
personal your personal feeling about the
media frenzy about the corona virus we
all know that varies a media frenzy here
and what is what it is you think about
this thing I mean are we are we making
too much headlines about the corona
virus right now or too little it's
really hard to understand I'd like to
have your personal thoughts on that
Thanks I'll take the genetic sequencing
one first on the virus and then the more
existential ones after that the remember
in this that China Chinese scientists
probably the most rapid characterization
of a novel pathogen in history and that
was shared immediately multiple
sequences were shared immediately on
global platforms and that is what is the
load a lot of the Diagnostics to be
developed the difference in the advance
ensuring the virus is that the virus
itself allows you to grow the virus
you're able to test in vitro drugs
against the virus you're able to do all
kinds of other things when you have the
worse China has isolated that virus and
China is not against and China is now
currently working with partners to see
how it can share the virus there is no
there's no obstacle to that from the
Chinese perspective we're already
working with Chinese colleagues and we
had I had direct discussions with the DG
and ministers in China on that gesture
that there's no resistance to that
happening we do though command our
colleagues particularly in Australia and
in the in the Institute there who the
darling Institute who are a whu-oh
collaborating Center by the way one of
our global partners who've rapidly been
able to do that but other partners of
them as well a Maria may wish to speak
to the - that collaboration around virus
isolation and sharing with regard to
what we learned on the on the trip I
mean it was an obviously a very short
mission but what what I took away from
that mission was the absolute
relentless and focused determination of
the government of China to put the
health of people in China ahead of
anything else at this point and to take
what our significant economic and other
hits in order to put the health of
people first and certainly the levels of
meetings and the number of meetings and
the attendance that those meetings was
unprecedented in my memory in terms of
the government's commitments to do that
so I I don't know if that's a good
enough answer I did we didn't see all
sorts of new days where we didn't see
all sorts of new evidence but what we
really got a sense of was that and that
commitment and and and and laser focus
on this been the absolute top priority
with that in mind we have a chance
because when a government is that
committeth when a government is that
willing to be transparent than we do
have a chance so we have a job to do in
China to support China in doing that we
have a job to do in supporting countries
that already have imported cases and we
still have an opportunity to stop this
virus and it may evolve we we have to
and we had the same issues and my
unfortunately my memories go back to
Sarah's
and we had very many of the same
questions during the early days of SARS
can this be controlled which way is it
spreading and at the time I said we have
to base our actions on imperfect
evidence there will never be enough
information to make a perfect decision
but if we don't make decisions and act
therefore we don't take any opportunity
so this is really where science public
health and policy meet can we gather
enough evidence and make good
evidence-based decisions that are
rational and can we use that evidence to
drive a public health strategy that can
stop the disease with the minimum impact
on society the minimum impact on economy
and can we balance those two things
because we have to and this is coming to
your question
on the the media issues around the world
of course people are concerned why
wouldn't people be concerned a new virus
has emerged we don't have a therapy we
don't have a vaccine that disease has
emerged and crossed the species barrier
it has spread and caused a major
epidemic in China that's a concern and
people shouldn't be criticized for
having that concern but I do think we
need to also focus on what to do in a
crisis it's very easy to - sometimes
I've called it that something must be
done club where people say something
must be done well unfortunately we don't
have the opportunity to say something
should be done we must decide what needs
to be done and we must get on and do it
and can we find a way to make that
happen and we need partners in the media
to work with us in that effective risk
communication is the most powerful tool
we have at our disposal right now in the
absence of vaccine in the absence of
drugs and our colleagues in the media
are a channel to populations you also
are there to keep us accountable and
that's a very important part of your job
but you also communicate with vulnerable
people who can protect themselves how
you choose to communicate risk is very
important so it's a challenge to you as
well as to us how do we do that together
how do we share rational information on
the risk rational information on how to
manage that risk while also holding
authorities and institutions to account
for doing that properly and there's no
answers to that and maybe I'm giving you
a very philosophical answer but I've
been around I've been around this this
track so many times that that is
essentially the balance we have to find
between the communications and media
community and ourselves and maybe Maria
can add on the sequencing because it is
important to understand the extra
advantages that virus sharing gives you
over sequence theory yeah just just a
compliment what mike has said the rapid
sharing I mean this the rap when we say
rapid we mean days I mean the
availability of having
full genome sequence of a novel virus
available to the public to be able to
develop Diagnostics to be able to
diagnose patients and other countries is
unprecedented the world is not alert and
the fact that they had these sequences
available made them able to use PCR
testing use full genome sequencing to
identify these cases quickly so this is
this is why we are seeing cases why the
evolution of this is so quick and this
is the positive and just to say with
with regards to the virus sharing it is
essential that viruses are shared so
that the further development of
diagnostics and serologic assays so that
the further development of therapeutics
and vaccines can continue
thank you very much Mario just to let
you know that W - director-general dr.
terrorists is joining us shortly so if
you have some questions for him just
wait for that briefs from Bloomberg and
then Stephanie and then we will go to a
couple of questions from journalists
watching guys on wgo twitter account
briefs please thank you for your
comments I just wanted to follow up on
the transparency question can you
provide some clarity as to why
information about the disease was
suppressed around the time of this
month's legislative meetings in
Providence and his follow up do you
believe this has had an effect on
China's response to the growing epidemic
thank you it'd be good if you could
specify what you mean by that because
certainly if you attract the Wuhan
website the public website since the
very beginning of this they've had red
alert and they've been warning the
population so it's very early in this
response in fact I think it's probably a
state of the art in terms of the the
amount of information that's been
published by the state authorities in
this case so if you just be good to
understand well what the the core of
your question is and do you have a day's
in a timeline where you're concerned
about this in terms of dates yeah it was
the the provinces CPPCC Congress
meetings from January 11th to the 17th
but
my understanding is that the the
information around the epidemic was
being tracked right for the 31st 1st of
January so we can come back to you
afterwards with some of the numbers but
certainly the the government authorities
in in in in Wuhan were publishing daily
numbers since the early part of the year
and had issued major alerts to the
population in advance of that in advance
of those dates you mentioned we can go
through some of the dates with you but
it's more broadly would you say that you
believe that China has been transparent
about this disease and it's and do you
think the infection controls are
adequate
from my perspective China has been very
open in in reporting its cases on a
daily basis to us we've seen no obvious
lack of transparency and but when you
speak about that in general we can see
issues with transparency around the
world in terms of case has been reported
of anything but I would see in this
particular case a huge difference and I
was involved in 2002 and 3 in SAS and I
can tell you from direct operational
experience that there is no comparison
between the behavior of China then and
the behavior of China now and countries
are always sensitive when I would point
you to any of the other surrounding
countries that have imported cases
including some very large ones they're
always sensitive about sharing
information about new diseases and in
fact some countries have laws that don't
allow them to do that because there are
issues around the national security so I
think before we start pointing the
finger at China we also need to
recognize that there are genuine
sensitivities around sharing data around
new diseases and I believe in this case
the countries that have been affected
including China have been remarkably
transparent in this regard thank you
thank you very much I'll give a floor
now to dr. Tetris WTO director-general
apologies we were supposed to come
together actually all of us but I was in
a governance meeting our P back so
that's why I'm late but I'm glad you
continued so some of the things I say
could be a repeat because I didn't know
what my kid or what Maria said and I
hope you will bear with me as you know
we have just returned from China and
yesterday we had the opportunity to meet
with President Xi Jinping Minister of
Health ma Xiao Wei and Minister of
Foreign Affairs Wang Yi prior to my
visit I was in almost daily contact with
Minister MA to discuss the response to
the outbreak and how whu-oh can support
because we need to focus on the
epicenter of the outbreak managing the
outbreak at the epicenter helps us from
the outbreak spreading to the rest of
the world and during my visit we had a
serious a series of very candid
discussions based on mutual
understanding our discussions focused on
continued collaboration on containment
measures in Wuhan public health measures
in other cities and provinces conducting
further studies on the severity and
transmissibility of the virus and
sharing data and biological material I
was very encouraged and impressed by the
president's detailed knowledge of the
outbreak and his personal involvement in
the response
this is this was for me a very rare
leadership in his words the measures
they have taken are good not only for
China but for the rest of the world
Premier Li has also been on the ground
in Wuhan to understand the outbreak and
direct the response China's efforts to
contain the outbreak at the epicenter
have been essential for preventing the
third further spread of the virus
China identified the pathogen in record
time and shared it immediately which led
to the rapid development of diagnostic
tools they're completely committed to
transparency both internally and
externally and they have agreed to work
with other countries who need their
support for example the cases in Germany
reported yesterday originated with a
Chinese woman who traveled from Shanghai
to Germany for professional purposes
she was asymptomatic on arrival but
became ill shortly before taking her
return flight to China after her return
to China she was tested and found to be
positive as well her parents who had
visited her from Wuhan prior to her
departure Chinese authorities
immediately notified their counterparts
in Germany who were able to take prompt
action this example is a good
illustration of how China is engaging
with whu-oh and other countries based on
the principles of solidarity and
cooperation to address a global health
emergency President Xi and I agreed that
WH er will lead a team of international
experts to visit China as soon as
possible
to work with the government on
increasing the unders
turning of the outbreak to guide global
response if efforts in total as you know
there are now six thousand sixty five
confirmed cases including five thousand
nine hundred ninety seven in China
representing almost ninety nine percent
of all cases worldwide 132 people have
lost their lives to this outbreak all of
them in China our thoughts are with
their families but outside China there
are only 68 confirmed cases in 15
countries which is 1% of total and no
deaths the vast majority of cases
outside China have a travel history to
China or contact with someone with a
travel history to China there are signs
of a few cases of human-to-human
transmission outside China in three
countries which we are monitoring very
closely the fact that today we have only
seen 68 cases outside China and nodes'
is deal in no small part to the
extraordinary steps the government has
taken to prevent the export of cases for
that China deserves our gratitude and
respect and they're doing that at the
expense of their economy and other
factors tablature is monitoring this
outbreak every moment of every day we
share the concern of many people who
worried for their own health and that of
their friends and family the emergence
of any new pathogen with the potential
to cause severe illness and death is of
grave concern and must be taken with
utmost seriousness this is exactly what
we are doing now more than ever is the
time for being guided by the science and
making
rational evidence-based decisions we're
working closely with public health
authorities in each of the affected
countries to track the spread and
virulence of the virus and we're
providing guidance on countermeasures to
protect public health the continued
increase in cases and the evidence of
human team and transmission outside
China are of course was deeply
concerning although the numbers outside
China are still relatively small they
hold the potential for a much larger
outbreak I have therefore decided to
reconvene the International Health
Regulations
Emergency Committee on novel coronavirus
2019 to advise me on whether the
outbreak represents a public health
emergency of international concern and
to seek their recommendations on how
best to protect people all over the
world while recognizing what China is
doing very serious measures and we can't
ask for more we understand the vital
importance of keeping member states
fully briefed to ensure the
recommendations of the committee are
implemented consistently we are
therefore also proposing tomorrow
briefings to member states so thank you
so much again for bearing with me and
apologies for joining you late
thank you thank you very much
director-general so we are getting lots
of questions online some of them have
been already answered so we will try to
take some of those a little bit later
those that have not been touched upon
yet but now we continue from the room
first
Stephanie then Nina and then John and
then we will go online yes thank you
good timing the director-general perhaps
this is best for you if you have your
earphone maybe
you've you've come back from China sir
with with this promise from those
Chinese authorities of being able to
send an international mission a
multidisciplinary mission you said again
today the same language that you hope to
send as soon as possible and you're
working on it can you tell us a little
bit more about what sort of skills
you're looking for how large it might be
what guarantees you've had from the
government as to access and very
specifically the u.s. health secretary
as our has voiced some concerns that
wanting to get us experts on the ground
in China do you have plans to include us
experts from CDC or other agencies in
this this mission or is it a stumbling
block in fact no thank you by the way as
we speak we have already some colleagues
from the village on the ground and we
already have our director Sylvie Brown
who stayed behind who were part of our
mission and then we will put together
others from WH HSN but we're discussing
with what skill sets we need we need to
send on involving other countries the
best would be bilateral arrangement and
that's what we recommend because the WH
experts will be those who work for WH o
or who we may identify identify that can
work as independent experts if we lack
expertise in in in WH o but with
countries it should be a bilateral and
that's what we expected thank you very
much Nina then John and then we will
take few questions from and then
hopefully we will come back here
Nina Larson AFP I was wondering there
now
quite large-scale evacuations from from
China if you could say how good idea you
think it is that countries are
evacuating their citizens and pretend
and the potential of further spread
through that also the isolation
isolation that some countries are doing
and also I was wondering on it seems
that the you were saying 2% 2% death
death so far sounds a lot less serious
than perhaps an irregular flu could you
just say say something about that and
also about inclusion of Taiwan in X in
the emergency meetings they're
complaining that they're being excluded
and doesn't that leave the possibility
that there will be a blind spot that the
survivors could spread in Taiwan